mais d'abord donc ses citoyens français
qui font route vers paris avec un mot
d'ordre la liberté mais sans leader ni
revendication structure et forcément ça
nous rappelle quelque chose j'ai attendu
priait
les routes du canadien ne désarment pas
à ottawa entre 400 et 500 poids lourds
blocs la capitale fédérale depuis dix
jours derrière le mouvement intitulé
convoi pour la liberté ces camionneurs
s'opposent à la nouvelle loi sur
l'obligation vaccinale
les lois qu'ils ont prises leurs petites
règles et obligations n'ont aucun sens
leurs obligations vont beaucoup trop
loin et il faut revenir à la liberté il
faut revenir où nous étions avant
sur place la situation est jugée hors de
contrôle par les autorités qui ont
déclenché l'état d'urgence restait
silencieux plusieurs jours le premier
ministre canadien justin trudeau a
finalement demandé aux manifestants de
lever le siège de la ville les canadiens
ont le droit de manifester de s'opposer
au gouvernement et de faire entendre
leur voix on va toujours protéger ce
droit mais soyons clairs ils n'ont pas
le droit de faire obstruction à
l'économie à la démocratie ou au
quotidien de nos concitoyens c'est assez
hors du canada le mouvement commence à
faire tâche d'huile états unis nouvelle
zélande mais aussi en france où de
multiples convoi pour la liberté
s'organise comme ici à nice
des pages facebook structure la
mobilisation principalement orientée
contre le pass vaccinale ce groupe par
exemple rassemble plus de 300 mille
membres et d'autres se développe à
vitesse grand v comme celle créée par
sylvain des roches est un entrepreneur
de haute garonne qui
se passe
vraiment un moment extrêmement
ces convois de la liberté on tente aussi
lutter pour le pouvoir d'achat contre la
hausse du prix de l'essence ou encore le
manque de représentativité démocratique
des revendications proche de celle des
gilet jaune ces convois devrait
s'élancer samedi partout en france vers
la capitale
mobilisation que le gouvernement dit
prendre très au sérieux
et on tente d'analyser ce mouvement
naissant en france avec michel wieviorka
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
professeur à l'école des hautes études
en sciences sociales et vous venez de
publier métamorphose ou d'échéance où va
la france c'est aux éditions rue de
seine jacques également béatrice giblin
bonsoir soir vous retrouvez vous êtes
géographe directrice de la revue
hérodote
j'accueille également sylvain boulouque
comment soir aussi historien spécialiste
du communisme des mouvements anarchistes
de l'extrême gauche vous publiez le pen
le peuple c'est aux éditions atlandes
alors c'est pas ceni jean marigny
marines et julien le pen qui était
militant syndicaliste libertaire des
années 30 voilà pourquoi grosse conne et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique selon mathieu heureux de vous
retrouver évidemment alors c'est
toujours difficile d'analyser à un
mouvement naissant on va être prudent je
pense cependant pendant ce débat michel
wieviorka mais est ce que on l'a vu dans
le reportage est ce que voilà c'est ce
parallèle son retour des gilet jaune ça
nous vient à l'esprit ça vous vient à
l'esprit forcément oui mais je résiste
beaucoup je réside beaucoup parce qu'il
ya énormément de différence et je dirais
les gilet jaune c'est plutôt un
mouvement social et les dimensions
sociales sont centrales
ce nouveau mouvement c'est plutôt un
anti mouvement si j'ose dix ans tout en
tout cas ce n'est pas un mouvement qui
construit qui propose qui essaient de
construire quelque chose et n'est pas
social
le coeur de la faire c'est le vaccin
c'est le pass sanitaires et par
conséquent une chose est de critiquer le
vaccin l'accident cet état c'est quand
même autre chose que de dire les
produits pétroliers les taxes sur les
produits pétroliers sont trop lourds le
jeu n'arrive pas à boucler mon moi
j'habite dans un désert social etc et
donc je crois qu'il faut ne pas trop
faire de parallèle et j'ajouterais parce
que le deuxième parallèle qu'on veut
qu'on vient de voir ses les camionneurs
canadien oui c'est un monde tellement
différent de notre monde à nous ce monde
des camionneurs canadien je connais un
peu celui des camionneurs américains ça
doit pas être très très différents et
donc déry parler d'elle avec un anglais
très c'était pas des québécois qu'on
entendait et donc je trouve vraiment
qu'il faut être prudent dans les
comparaisons prudent dans les
comparaisons béatrice giblin
effectivement et cette source
d'inspiration canadienne bon pour
glissement être prudent il ya très peu
de camionneurs français mobilisés donc
bon et puis et puis peut-être les gilet
jaune pardon mais jugeant que c'était un
mouvement original en français là là on
copie légale à la fois ça c'est oui avec
une grande différence c'est à dire que
vos chauffeurs canadiens sont
propriétaires de leur camion ça et que
les chauffeurs français sont salariées
d'entrepreneurs on a vu un entrepreneur
qui est à l'origine par aman monsieur
des rochettes de l'organisation du
mouvement mais on a un seul
de ce fait on risque fort aussi d'avoir
on a dit des camping-cars des piètres
des caravanes ou des mini bus bus je
pense qu'on va avoir des choses qui
n'ont pas du tout la loure de ce convoi
ottawa ça sera tout à fait tout à fait
différent qu'on soit prudent sur la
comparaison se rejoindraient michel
wieviorka que les gens qui vont
manifester eux se projette dans ce cas
et émouvants des gilets jaunes sûrement
c'est à dire que je pense que les
manifestants ne rompt pas la prudence
que nous pouvons avoir ce soir ils vont
essayer de retrouver une dynamique on
avait vu les manifestations des anti vax
pendant l'été ça revenait tous les
samedis comme ont essayé de rejouer au
fond ce qui s'était joué avec les les
gilet jaune et on avait vu avec une
chute assez rapide quand même entre des
manifestations qui ont été autour de 200
milles puis on est tombé au bout de 3
quelle semaine à 30 mille voix voire
vingt mille donc il y à un contexte moi
qui me semble très différents c'est à
dire il y avait une forme de sympathie
moi j'ai toujours été très prudente sur
l'idée du soutien rouges et les jaunes
et y avait une sorte de sympathie aux
mouvements des gilet jaune dans
l'opinion publique française je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il retrouve cette même
sympathie dans le mouvement qui va qui
est qui merde je suis moi je te
la dit on la dit qu on avoue qu'on
souhaitait de foudre la parole mais si
mon boulot coup sûr sur cet aspect là
effectivement le sait sur notre trop tôt
pour répondre à la question mais est ce
qu'on peut imaginer une sympathie de
l'opinion pour ce mouvement naissance je
sais pas il ya plusieurs éléments déjà
les deux grandes fédérations de
camionneurs ou de routiers fo et la cftc
n'appelle pas n'appelle pas du tout
mouvement donc on n'est pas de après il
va falloir faire très attention parce
qu'on retrouve quand même un certain
nombre d'animateurs du gilet jaune il va
falloir faire très attention au local
sur les images tout à l'heure qu'on a pu
voir les manifestants qui partent à nice
et partenaires plutôt aux franges les
plus radicales à droite de l'échiquier
politique avait un drapeau avec une
fleur de lis
une croix un choeur vendéen pardon donc
on était on était plutôt sur cette
frange la de l'échiquier politique
lierre et se trouve que j'étais sur une
chaîne concurrente est un des
intervenants
un des animateurs d'un des collectifs se
réclamait du comité invisible donc
plutôt de de l'autre
après il ya donc ça dépendra vraiment
des régions si on prend la région
nantaise je pense que les revendications
seront beaucoup plus social que celle
du sud de la france après il ya d'autres
éléments qu'on ne maîtrise pas du tout
parce qu'il ya une colère ont un
désinvestissement qui peut exister il ya
qu'à voir les taux d'abstention qui
s'annonce record est ce qu'un tel
mouvement qui mélange le social le
politique
les différentes questions peut prendre
ou est ce que est ce qu'il est trop tard
par rapport à l'échéance électorale est
ce qu'ils vont profiter des chances
électorales après soit le nombre de
pages facebook et tout ça je serais
beaucoup plus réservé dans la mesure où
c'est quand même ça recoupe ça recoupe
quand même grandement elle n'est pas
gelé gilet jaune et le nombre de
personnes qui me suivent et j'ai les
jaunes qui pouvaient suivre les gels et
j'espère qu'on est à peu près quand même
dans le même temps de deux personnes qui
suivent ce mouvement et qui est
finalement peut-être même la même
structure sociologique aux politiques
car déjà les jo dit il ya peut-être pas
mal de similitudes
s'il y en a certainement qui viennent de
ce mouvement ils soient prêts à changer
les mots d'ordre pour alors ce qui est
sûr c'est que le gouvernement suit ça de
près le gouvernement ne minimise pas les
risques notamment risque de blocage et
on écoute le ministre de l'intérieur
c'était hier sur bfm nous prenons les
choses au sérieux ce qui est certain
c'est que nous mettons les moyens de
renseignement et d'action si jamais des
gens voulaient bloquer la liberté des
uns et des autres surtout un accès à la
capitale donc les moyens sont importants
la réponse de l'état sera extrêmement
fertile c'est le cas aujourd'hui nous
n'avons pas de renseignements qui
démontre que ce que vous dites est tout
à fait constitué est vrai au monde mais
nous sommes très attentifs les policiers
les gendarmes sont très mobilisés et
nous prendrons les nos responsabilités
pour ne jamais laisser entraver la
liberté circulation battus à un premier
mot sur ce le calendrier politique le
mouvement on verra il va peut-être faire
pschitt il va peut-être grandir mais il
peut compliquer l'entrée en campagne de
mâcon et le calendrier politique en tout
cas ce mouvement est curieux parce qu'on
est prêt à mettre deux mois d'une
présidentielle donc le meilleur moyen de
signifier sa colère ou vous montrez sa
protestation s'est même de voter il y
avait très longtemps à attendre pendant
ces deux mois ces questions c'est que le
gouvernement ne redoute pas forcément
une grande solidarité et une grande
sympathie des français ils redoutent par
pardonnez moi l'expression un bordel
parce que pour le coup c'est la face
noire du quinquennat macron cette crise
dg jaune pour mille raisons parce qu'il
l'exécutif a mis beaucoup de temps à en
prendre la mesure a mis beaucoup de
temps à trouver comment la gérer et il a
plutôt joué sur l'usure que sur une
véritable négociation parce que c'était
pas facile à négocier puis n'a pas su
l'encadré on a bien vu tous les
débordements qui aiderait manifestation
entre les rapports entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'anp donc
il est hors de question pour l'exécutif
de voir quelque chose de ce type
réapparaître raison pour laquelle le
miso l'intérieur hier d oncle est hors
de question de bloquer d'entraver la
sécurité de la circulation il devrait
avoir des mesures assez ferme qui qui
qui m'a prise mais ils ont l'air de dire
nice à l'intérieur que le service de
renseignement territoriaux ne table pas
forcément sur une immense mobilisation
après il arrive à tout le monde de se
tromper évidemment à suivre michel
wieviorka scission alors moi je reste
quand même je m'accroche quand même un
peu au mouvement des jeunes pour essayer
d'analyser le plus dur est plus là on
avait le sentiment que la violence
servait un peu de plus petit
dénominateur commun donc c'est aussi
certainement compagne et le bordel des
craintes du gouvernement
alors l'histoire la violence des filets
jaunes c'est une histoire compliquée
parce que ça commence de l'extérieur du
mouvement c'est plutôt les black blocks
- d'ailleurs m'enfin des ultras de
droite bon et puis
des acteurs des gilets jaunes vont
rentrer dans des logiques de violence
pas forcément de manière centrale mais
ça peut arriver soit chaud ici vous êtes
dans une manifestation il ya des choses
qui vous semble choquant vous vous
embarquez
c'est compliqué pour nous observateurs
aux journalistes on disait gilet jaune
et puis gilet jaune radicaliser on
essayait de faire la différence voilà il
est l'autre il ya eu des logiques de ce
type et puis aussi des logiques de gens
qui changent du bon bah oui oui je vais
passer à la violence de façon plus plus
construite si je peux dire donc déjà le
rapport à la violence est différent mais
je raciste et sur deux points dont on
n'a pas encore parlé ce soir premier
point c'est la dimension européenne de
cette affaire l'horizon des gilets
jaunes c'est l etat nation c'était on
veut orléans macro on veut aller à
l'elysée c'était vraiment le le cadre là
on nous dit paris et qu'une étape allant
à bruxelles on va aller à bruxelles et
ça j'en ai voulu quatre ans et la
douceur je ne suis pas certain que ce
soit un signe de force je pense que
c'est plutôt un signe de faiblesse de ce
mouvement et de difficulté est bon en
tout cas ça vienne nous dire autre chose
cette première main et puis la deuxième
remarque les gilet jaune ce qui a fait
leur force aussi c'est pas seulement les
manifestations dans les grandes villes
c'est aussi le fait qu'ils étaient sûrs
du local c'était je vais au rond-point
du supermarché de ma commune et je
retrouve des gens que j'ai appris à
connaître que je fréquente viavil il y
avait un ancrage local
c'est pas le cas ici les gens prennent
leur voiture les ont les moyens je
dirais même de prendre une voiture une
caravane enfin donc c'est assez
différent donc je crois je ne dis pas du
tout que ce mouvement est condamné à
dépérir personnes peu je crois que ce
serait pas sérieux parler comme ça en
plus il peut lui arriver un invariant à
ce mouvement comme à d'autres c'est à
dire après tout ils commencent plutôt
solitaire et puis c'est sylvia un
instant il peut y avoir des dimensions
sociales
le prix de l'essence salon donc il faut
être c'est pour ça qu'il faut être
prudent dans les dents le moindre
pronostic
mais rien n'interdit de deux insisté sur
les différences alors on a regardé on a
cherché un peu les les hashtag les mots
diez pour pour appeler à fait route vers
paris puis bruxelles y en a plein un
convoi de liberté alors il ya eu les
versions effectivement européenne qu'on
ne veuille french lines officiel convoi
pour la liberté qu'on le veuille ou loeb
pour nouveau convoi france 2022 bref il
y en a plein c'est une des une façon
d'illustrer on peut dire l'hétérogénéité
du mouvement il y en a une autre c'est
tout simplement d'aller chercher sur les
réseaux sociaux ceux qui disent on fait
route vers paris alors là on va trouver
des cas de figure très différente n'est
4 on va les appeler des convoyeurs en
route vers paris regardez aujourd'hui
c'est une convergence qui est totalement
pacifistes avec des gens avec une grande
droiture des choses des citoyens qui
veulent juste défendre les valeurs de
leur pays qui veulent défendre leur pays
qui veulent défendre leurs enfants qui
veulent défendre leur liberté et qui
veulent aussi défendre leurs droits de
vivre correctement dans les années
futures une contre société qui n'est pas
du tout dans la violence qui n'est pas
du tout dans la bière dans la
malveillance qui au contraire et dans la
solidarité dans le l'humanité qu'ils ont
le dialogue dans la démocratie fait
appel à tous les jeunes de france on va
manifester contre le pass on va
manifester contre les taxes sur
l'énergie on en a marre on est en train
de tous crever littéralement si on se
prend pas en main maintenant on va
vraiment bouffer de la merde alors nous
mais le masque aujourd'hui demain on
aura plus d'essence après demain on aura
plus de souffle
je vous laisse imaginer sans quoi on va
sombrer ces prochaines années alors ceux
qui pensent que le monde va s'améliorer
que le comique va passer et que ce sera
fini j'ai envie de vous dire réveillez
vous les gens il faut arrêter de
regarder 20h prenez le temps de vous
informer sur ce qui se passe réellement
là on est un peu dans le discours
la limite du complotisme mathieu ce qui
est intéressant c'est que ces convois
ils rejoignent une longue liste de
colère citoyenne ont une longue liste
colère citoyenne qui déroutent
particulièrement pouvoir en pensant à
penser au gilet jaune bien évidemment
mais moi j'y ajoute c'est les
mobilisations qu'on voit depuis quelques
années alors qu'ils sont toutes
différentes et que ce soit certaine
marge pour le climat ou de 5 sur bellion
ou certaines occupations à 10 tout le
mouvement nuit debout ça déconcerte le
pouvoir parce que ces mobilisations à
son particulière je le disais pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord parce qu'elles
sont pas lancés par des organisations
politiques ou syndicales existantes et
qu'elle se bat avec plus ou moins de
succès contre toute forme de
récupération ensuite parce qu'elles sont
protéiformes sylvain boulouque le disait
elle agrège démobilisés qui viennent
d'horizons idéologiques ou politiques
divers chacun ajoutant au pot commun
parfois les sujets qui les concernent
avec pour le plus grand bonheur de
certains qui croient à la convergence
des luttes mais souvent au final quand
même un grand fourre-tout parfois un
grand n'importe quoi elles n'ont
généralement pas de représentant ni
porte parole et se désolidarise très
vite des figures qui se revendique comme
tel elles n'ont pas la culture du
mouvement social en michel wievorka elle
disait parce que ça il ya des règles il
ya des codes de mouvement social ce ça
se ressent d'ailleurs aussi bien dans
les manifestations que dans les
négociations en gros elles ne savent ni
se comporter ou se confronter à la
police ni parler aux gouvernants et puis
je trouve qu'un autre point commun de
toutes ces mobilisations là c'est
qu'elle n'offre pas de débouchés
politiques claires la mobilisation il
dépasse souvent la revendication on ne
fait pas grève de sitting pour obtenir
satisfaction sur un point précis à part
peut-être dans les mobilisations à dist
et encore parce qu'en gros on se
mobilise quand même souvent pour crier
sa colère réinventer le monde avec en
résumé en un mot d'ordre commun plus
petit dénominateur commun à toutes ces
mobilisations qui est être pris en
considération
et comment les pouvoirs publics peuvent
tenter d'y répondre ils sont bien
embêtés évidemment parce que toutes ces
mobilisations souligne en creux
l'essoufflement de notre système
démocratique au même titre que la montée
de l'abstention petits plaisirs
référence brice teinturier avait
théorisé ça il ya quelques années en
parlant du praf pour ceux qui n'en n'ont
plus rien à moi je trouve ces
différents de l'abstention pour le coup
parce que ceux-là ont précisément
quelque chose à même s'ils ont
parfois du mal à exprimer ce pour quoi
et et même si c'est souvent très
compliqué jeudi répond la première
réponse cac avait trouvé le président de
république pour les gilet jaune c'était
d'essayer de renouer le dialogue avec
son grand débat oncav est intervenu un
peu tard et puis qui était surtout un
monologue épuise les associés d'une
certaine façon les citoyens au travers
d'un grand projet qui était la
convention climat mais le naturel est
vite revenu au galop et on en a vite vu
je disais les limites l'autre réponse à
mes yeux c'est de revivifier les corps
intermédiaires qui ont quand même été
largement écrasé ou écartés par pendant
son quinquennat pour que puisse
s'exprimer de façon plus structurée
jeudi par récupérer mais en tout cas ses
revendications à travers des canaux
associatifs syndicaux ou des collectifs
citoyens qu'ils soient nouveaux on sait
pas forcément les syndicats qui existent
aujourd'hui mais qui ne doivent plus
être pris de haut puis enfin la dernière
réflexion ccc pour le coup n'aurait
réflexion sur la rénovation de notre vie
politique sur la représentation
démocratique comme sur l'exercice du
pouvoir est là à tous les niveaux jédir
du municipal au national et avec de
vraies réformes pas des gadgets il
s'agit pas de jus c'est un budget
participatif dans une ville où on fait
voter est ce qu'on fait un bon ou non
jardin public j'exagère mais en gros il
faut vraiment repenser de ce point de
vue là la représentation démocratique et
l'exercice du pouvoir et de ce point de
vue emmanuel macron tu promettais
l'avènement d'un nouveau monde a quand
même beaucoup beaucoup déçu nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans une forme d'entre d'eux
comme le disait le philosophe italien
antonio gramsci vous connaissez tous
voilà que la crise est quand le vieux
monde ne summer et que le neuf ne peut
pas naître en broutards l'apparaître il
ajouté et dans ce clair obscur
surgissent mais bon c'est un surgissent
les monstres béatrice giblin c'est un
enjeu majeur de quel que soit le
vainqueur de cette présidentielle
rénové réinventer notre vie politique je
voudrais simplement faire d'abord une
remarque parce que l'expression de la
colère on dire mais c'est vraiment parce
que notre système démocratique ne
fonctionne pas ici on avait eu des
réseaux sociaux il ya déjà 10 20 ans 30
ans aurait fonctionné de la même façon
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que le rôle des
réseaux sociaux est absolument essentiel
dans la façon dont ça fonctionne de
façon horizontale ouvrant ses ouailles
et moi le signe d'un essoufflement notre
démocratie en tout cas je suis persuadé
que si ça avait existé ya 30 ans aurait
fonctionné aussi comme ça et je pense
qu'on aurait eu un discours qui n'aurait
pas été si différent sur le problème de
notre démocratie ou autre je crois qu'
il faut tenir compte de ce contexte là
c'est d'une certaine façon facile si
vous voulez allier coin très différent
de la france et puis bon très très
simplement on peut se donner rendez-vous
umanis a très très bien on fait une
carte les points d'hébergement les
points où vous aurez du ravitaillement
qui tout ça est très amusant tout ça est
très excitant dans des vies qui parfois
peuvent paraître un peu un peu
banale ou voire ennuyeuse il ya dans les
gilet jaune ya eu c'est ce que rappelait
michel wievorka le plaisir de se
retrouver et de faire une bonne bouffe
arroser si possible c'était quand même
de la chaleur humaine de bas et on a je
crois de nouveau quelque chose comme ça
ce qui me fait dire qu'on ne peut
vraiment pas prédire si ça va marcher ou
pas pour peu qu'il fasse un peu beau que
ça aille bien que ça prenne on peut
avoir un peu un peu de monde partir la
dent dernière chose allait quand même
parce que se plaindre du prix du
carburant et se permette de faire un
bayonne paris bruxelles
simplement pour le relais il faut quand
même avoir les moyens de remplir champ
s'il va savoir intervenir si je n'ai pas
fait insisté sur les faire et réseaux
sociaux 5 quand même là on a une
mobilisation ou même pour les jo dans
les mobilisations qui était de la
première fois trois cent mille personnes
après 158 personnes les organisations
syndicales
quand elles appellent à manifester il ya
trois cent mille personnes dans la rue
la différence c'est que les gilets
jaunes ça a été réseaux réseaux sociaux
plus chaîne d'information continue que
ça a été une parole qui a été reprise en
permanence
vous assistez à une manifestation
syndicale c'est trente secondes à la fin
d'une d'un journal quel qu'il soit alors
que le nombre de participants peut-être
identique voire voire supérieur donc
l'attrait de la nouveauté c'est
l'intérêt de la nouveauté c'est celle et
fait effectivement réseaux sociaux c'est
à dire qu'il suffit et trois quatre
personnalités qui est soit un tout petit
peu influentes pour pour faire un
surcroît de mobilisation médiatique kif
qui pour d'autres formes de mobilisation
sociale n'existe pas même pour rebondir
sur l'extinction rébellion ce genre de
mouvement même ce genre de mouvement se
continue pourtant ils sont près de force
sur les réseaux sociaux quand il faut
une action ça n'a pas du tout la même
caisse de résonance que par contre là où
on peut comprendre que je termine là
dessus il y à un certaine influence
heures qui sont plutôt relayé par ce
qu'on appelle pour faire vite la
fachosphère et qui est immédiatement ce
genre de revendications c'était vrai
pour le dax surtout pour l'exemple anti
vaccins et c'est vrai aujourd'hui
immédiatement vous avez
d re tweeté et massivement parce que
c'est eux qui maîtrisent de mieux 7 oui
parce qu'ils étaient présents sur ces
réseaux sociaux avant que tout le monde
y aille jusque c'était leur seul canal
d'expression parce qu'il avait tout
moment d'être sourd et c'est ce qu'on
retrouve dans les médias c'est pareil
c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans la
mobilisation des camionneurs aussi alors
on adapte évidemment michel wieviorka je
vous parlais des corps intermédiaires
parce que c'est l'une des thématiques de
votre livre et notamment si on fait le
bilan du quinquennat macron c'est dire
que la situation n'était pas idéale
quand il est arrivé mais on n'a pas
vraiment arrangé les choses je pense
même qu'il les a très délibéremment très
délibéremment
[Musique]
accentuer le rejet la décomposition et
on leur donnait beaucoup d'exemples plus
spectaculaire c'est évidemment un bon
sens avec la cfdt la façon dont il a
géré même personnellement traité laurent
berger mais il n'ya pas que ça il n'y a
pas que ça il y a les associations alors
c'est intéressant parce qu'en même temps
c'est des vieux monde aussi donc toutes
les responsabilités sont pas d'un seul
côté mais on pourrait dire on peut
encourager le vieux monde à se
moderniser aussi les grandes
associations vont très mal mais
évidemment elle ne sont pas du tout aidé
et puis il ya des choses plus limité
mais moi qui m'ont frappé il ya d'abord
eu à faire de la laïcité y aurait un
observateur de la laïcité qui a été
traitée d'islam gauchistes ce qui était
quand même plus qu'excessive qui était
dirigée par jean louis bianco ont le
liquide en le faire mais on ne le
remplace pas on fait une structure
interministérielle qui ne veut rien dire
et donc on pourrait continuer on
pourrait trouver d'autres d'autres
illustrations donc oui on est dans une
situation où les corps intermédiaires
font défaut ne sont pas soutenues sont
faibles et ça ça a pesé extrêmement
lourd je suis convaincu et c'est une
c'est un peu ce que ce que vous disiez
je suis vraiment convaincu qu'on
comprend mieux ce qui se passe avec un
mouvement comme celui là si on analyse
en termes de crise de carence
ddd capacité de traitement politique de
traitement institutionnel des demandes
sociales c'est quand on écoute ce que
disent ces gens ça part vraiment dans
tous les sens moi j'étais frappé de tous
que de tout ce qu'on a on va dire qu'il
ya plus les réceptacles habituel de ses
colères de ses revendications cela
profite d'abord enfin si on revient au
gilet jaune et gilet jaune c'était des
gens qui se fichait complètement
problème du travail des primes de
l'entreprise j'étais ailleurs c'était
souvent des gens qui travaillaient
quelque part c'était pas d'être
uniquement des chômeurs ou non et donc
si vous voulez le sentiment que ce genre
de médiation ne fonctionne pas ne
fonctionne pas ça c'est très très très
très net alors et à autre chose que
j'aurais dire beaucoup des réseaux
sociaux mais tout ça fait fait système
les réseaux sociaux tout seul ça n'est
pas la certitude que les choses vous
marchez moi j'avais été très intéressés
par ce qu'on avait appelé le mouvement
des places au début des années 2010 et
les mouvements du printemps arabe toutes
ces choses là parce que ce qui faisait
la force de ces de ses acteurs c'est que
d'un côté réseau et d'un autre côté on
se retrouve concrètement et c'est ce qui
a fait aussi la force des gilet jaune
d'un côté réseau et d'un autre côté des
ronds-points ou les houles et les
carrefours où les manies et là une
énorme différence je trouve que ce
mouvement j'ai pris une cuite qui
faisait remarquer ces types qui ont les
moyens de prendre une bagnole de fer
perpi par qui aujourd'hui quel est le
gilet jaune moyens dit à la grande
époque des si les jaunes qui a les
moyens de dire moi je prends ma voiture
et je vais à paris puis à bruxelles
quand même c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose qui sait se couper quand même de
son de son ancrage local c'est plus
avoir le temps ça me faut avoir du temps
soyons francs qui seront exigées mais
voilà donc je crois aussi que cette là
le répertoire de cette mobilisation
s'éloigne plus qu'on ne le pense de
celui des gilets jaunes je voudrais
quand même con qu'on s'intéresse aussi à
la personnalité des manuels macron pour
plagier le titre vivre d'aunac et safran
pourquoi tant de haine il ya une
dimension anti macron aussi dans ce
mouvement sylvain boulouque alors il ya
plusieurs choses pour poursuivre c'est
michel c'est qu'à mon avis aussi ce
refus des corps intermédiaires ça vient
aussi la sociologie de la république
large comme vous regardez la sociologie
de la république en marche avoir
fréquents il ya peu d'élus locaux
d'anciens élus locaux et c'est quelqu'un
qui vienne du parti socialiste mais
majoritairement sont arrivés sans avoir
été c'était leur premier mandat donc ils
n'ont pas tout cette toute cette
connaissance du terrain c'est à dire à
savoir va connaître le responsable
syndical local où les responsables
syndicaux locaux le responsable de
l'union départementale donc tous ces
corps intermédiaires qui pourtant ont
fait la tradition mais même du gaullisme
enfin hugo liste conduit chiraquisme
sinon veut où et quand il y avait un
gros problème on pense à 95,7 amis à la
queen chirac prend son téléphone appelle
bergeron lui demandant qu'est-ce qu'il
faut que je fasse il ya des réponses
bergeron s'en vantait dans ses mémoires
en disant bon bah laisse tomber parce
que l'ancien l'ancien secrétaire général
de force du qu'il y avait sept
cette connaissance aussi du terrain des
deux côtés même avec même avec nicolas
sarkozy qui n'était pas fier eu de
l'histoire syndicale il y avait quand
même fait appel à raymond soubie ce qui
lui était un vieux
gaulliste formats existants le
ressentiment anti mâcon c'est aussi la
faiblesse de l'ancrage local de s'est
affaibli de l'ancrage local c'est à dire
qu'il ya d'abord une sociologie qui est
quand même csp + + savais que je crois
qu'il reste un enfant d'ouvrier à
l'assemblée nationale aujourd'hui c'est
tous les partis c'est dans tous les
partis c'est dans tous les parcs oui
mais enfin ça représente
cent comparé avec des périodes un peu
plus ancien il y avait beaucoup plus
vous voyez qu'il ya aujourd'hui et c'est
pas une raison mais alain t-mac rouge et
le canada ils sont titre udo c'est pas
mieux à ce qu'on a entendu tout à
l'heure c'est très violent aussi le côté
anti sciemment dit cela il ya le côté
anti mais il ya aussi derrière en france
quand même avec toutes ses dimensions
égalitariste qui qui peut perdurer
d'enfin qui perdu avec celle et gilet
jaune mais dans toutes les
manifestations des systématiquement une
référence à la révolution française à la
commune de bari donc à l'histoire de
france et les petits contre les contre
les gros et donc ça ça réactif après il
faut être mesuré parce que c'est aussi
un mail un phénomène minoritaire dans la
société c'est à dire que pour l'instant
il ya un matelas et oral pour quand même
on est président de la république est
quand même assez qui semble assez
important
avec ce serait non sur un dernier point
c'est qu'un taux d'abstention fier qui
est exponentielle chaque fois qu'on
parle des sondages ici beaucoup
d'incertitudes beaucoup de français qui
ne savent pas pour qui il va boire après
on sait que le taux d'abstention en fin
d'après ce qu'on peut voir dans les
enquêtes ça vient quand même
majoritairement des gens de gauche qui
se dit cette fois ci ce trop c'est trop
il n'ya pas voter
sur la personnalité là est la réponse
des manuels macron je vais vous donner
la parole dans un sens mais j'aurais
d'abord entendre un élément de réponse
qui était celui du porte-parole du
gouvernement c'était ce matin gabriel
attal juste après le conseil des
ministres comparaison avec d'autres pays
y regarder on sait qu'il ya une fatigue
et une fatigue et de lassitude des
français vis-à-vis de ce virus et des
mesures que nous avons dû prendre depuis
le début de cette crise pour protéger
les français il n'y a plus que quelques
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
en ont marre de cette épidémie qui en
ont marre de vivre avec ce virus est
depuis le début de cette crise en france
comme partout dans le monde des
mouvements politiques souvent radicaux
ont cherché à capitaliser sur cette
lassitude et cette fac tu es cette
fatigue pour essayer de créer des
mouvements moi ce que je veux rappeler
c'est que quand vous revenez quelques
semaines ou quelques mois en arrière la
france est probablement l'un des pays
d'europe qui a pris le moins de mesures
contraignantes le moins de mesures qui
entravent la liberté de ses concitoyens
c'est que c'est vrai béatrice giblin
sauf le il ya il ya quand même une
phrase d'emmanuel macron dont on se
souvient tous dans cette interview face
aux lecteurs du parisien aujourd'hui en
france il avait très envie d'emmerdés
ont vacciné on peut considérer aussi
dans le mouvement il ya un peu de ce
ressentiment qui oui bien sûr mais cette
phrase elle s'adressait aussi à tous les
vaccinés qui trouve effectivement
connaissance imax a commencé à l'iss
pour les emmerder cedex manqué son
mouvement naissant moi j'aimais bien
avec l'interview mais je pense que c'est
surtout qu'on copie ce qui s'est passé
au canada s'il n'y avait pas eu de
mouvement au canada il y aurait pas ce
mouvement là aujourd'hui en france faut
dire que l'opportunisme kidal qui sa
puissance et qu'ils en ont eu l'idée
parce que c'était ça qui se clippe au
fond on avait l'occasion de faire
quelque chose mais pour pour aller dans
le sens de ce que disait michel
wieviorka les quelques entrepreneurs qui
sont propriétaires de leurs camions et
qui vont parce que c'est pas comme
seulement avec quelques voitures que
vous allez réussir à faire un mouvement
de masse faudrait mieux qui est quand
même des gros véhicules donc si vous
avez des entrepreneurs avec leur camion
ça ne peut pas être du tout la même
chose que les gilet jaune avec des
grosses difficultés de faim moi posséder
un camion c'est déjà un capital
important c'est c'est cher un camion ça
ne se ça ne s'achète pas comme ça alors
peut-être qu'ils en vivent mal peut-être
qu'ils font des heures abominable tout
ça est possible mais on est
véritablement sur une sociologie qu'il
n'est pas à mon sens exactement
comparable à celle qu'on a vue dans le
cas des jeunes et jaune moi je la suis
je ne vous suis sans hésitation mais
n'est néanmoins dans cette situation
parfois d'énervement vous pouvez aussi
avoir toute une série vous on dit il
faut avoir le temps vous avez dit pour
pouvoir monter si vous avez des jeunes
retraités avec un petit peu juste le
moyen comme il faut qui voulaient pas se
faire vacciner qui bon et puis la csg
puis tout ce qu'on veut et puis nous on
est pas revalorisé on remet tous
ensemble on misait sauvegarder le
pouvoir d'achat de 0,6 il essaye de
mettre le pouvoir d'achat comme
revendication est pas sûr ces
différences culturelles entre le secteur
routier aux états unis et le secteur
routier secteur du transport routier en
france c'est des géants dans des flottes
de camions absolument considérable et
puis des artisans transporteurs qui sont
parfois deux trois camions mais qui sont
pas des gens riches qui sont des petits
patrons de pme et dans l'histoire des
conflits sociaux routier c'est soit des
conflits de salariés qui se battaient
pour des augmentations de rémunérations
pour des semaines qui soit parce que
vous avez des directives européennes sur
l'extension enfin bref soit des manifs
de petits patrons qui eux se protester
contre la libéralisation en europe et la
concurrence indue que leur faisait des
transporteurs routiers polonais ou là
mais on n'est pas d'ici à ce que tout ce
monde là se mobilisent pour enfin contre
le pass sanitaire contre le pacs final
je vois pas je vois pas la jointure ce
faire en revanche ce que vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur sur le chef de l'état
c'est quand même la traduction d'un
exercice du pouvoir qui moi je suis
d'accord avec michel wievorka est ce que
je vous disais il est à la pratique du
pouvoir quand même sur sur la
disparition des corps intermédiaires qui
a été assumée dès le début du
quinquennat à souder ou lula le travail
c'est par ordonnance enfin c'est elle
qu'on écrase tout on dit il faut faire à
marche forcée parce qu'il y avait dans
la vision d' emmanuel macron le
sentiment que les syndicats par exemple
étaient des rentiers du monde du monde
et qui vivait une forme de rente de
situation parce qu'ils étaient syndicats
parce qu'ils étaient représentées judy
ou jugés représentatifs par la loi qui
gérait des rentes de situation qui
empêchait de réformer la france au fond
et ça c'était profondément inscrite dans
le maquereau nisme alors après une
espèce de méprise parce que les gens ont
cru qu il était à la fois le fils
d'edmond maire et de michel rocard un
artisan du compromis à gauche qui allait
rénover le dialogue social et ils ont vu
un réformateur plus sarkozyste j'allais
dire en disant ça va se passer comme ci
comme ça et à marche forcée parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on peut débloquer la
france voilà c'était un point de vue
c'est je pense que c'est la façon dont
il a exercé le pouvoir qui fait que
voilà fait pas et puis même vis-à-vis
son parti comme y'a pas de parti comme
n'ya pas de courant dans son parti comme
n'y a pas de production d'idées dans son
parti tout vient d'en haut et quand tous
viendront vous vous heurtez un moment à
ce que
licence dubray il nous reste quelques
minutes le temps file c'est bon signe
sauf que ce débat est intéressant mais
j'aimerais qu'on évoque aussi le gain
politique
possible ou impossible d'ailleurs pour
les opposants d'emmanuel macron pour les
autres candidats à la
présidentielle alors y en avait une ce
matin sur europe 1 c'était marine le pen
est le représentant d'un autre adrien
cnas pour jean luc mélenchon les écoutes
c'est une autre forme du gilet jaune la
réalité c'est que nos sociétés la
mondialisation sauvage sans régulation
sans limitations posées par le pouvoir
politique pour protéger les populations
ont fait nos sociétés des cocottes
minutes il le moindre événement peut
faire sauter le couvercle de la cocotte
minute faut abroger maintenant le pass
vaccinale et en finir avec toutes ces
mesures liberticides qui n'ont pas
d'efficacité dans la jupe donc on verra
des insoumis dans le convoi ben moi je
si on a qui soit y aller en effet moi je
les encourage à y aller en effet il faut
arrêter avec cette logique là et y
compris il ya des revendications gelé vu
qu'ils sont aussi liées aux autres
problématiques notamment ses avait vu
les revoir la question bon voilà deux de
réactions qui sont intéressants michel
wieviorka sauf que mathieu le disais
tout à l'heure c'est un mouvement qui
est tellement hétérogènes sans vrai sans
vraie colonne vertébrale idéologique que
c'est aussi compliqué alors si on fait
le parallèle avec les jeunes pour les
opposants des macros d'en tirer profit
écoutez c'est très difficile de dire que
quiconque va en tirer profit
l'abstention peut-être mais et
indirectement
d'autres choses mais je vais faire
remarquer d'autre chose 1 il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont été vaccinés alors qu'il
ne voulait pas être vaccinés faut pas
dire que les gens tous les gens qui sont
vaccinés sont indifférents un mouvement
comme celui-là je suis convaincu qu'à
des gens vaccinés dans ce dans ce
mouvement la deuxième chose c'est que
parce que je crois que je crois qu'il
faut quand même garder l'idée c'est le
coeur de la faire cette question de la
vaccination est donc il ya quand même
les déclarations récentes je crois que
c'était ce matin où cet après-midi du
porte parole du gouvernement dix ans
d'ici la fin mars en principe si tout
continue à voilà c'est ça il y aura
pilpa et donc ou saas vaccin voilà et
donc moi je pense que ce mouvement qui
est déjà extrêmement composite enfants
de tous dic alors là il va être
totalement composite si la même puce ces
espèces de deux choses un peu centrale
qui est le lentilles vax élan et d'anti
passe si ça tombe fin mars début avril
on est on sera à dix jours du premier
tour ça tombe bien
la famille parce qu'il s'agit ça comme
ça mais c'est sur le gain éventuel
politique on a fait cette analyse au
moment du mouvement des gilet jaune est
ce qu'on peut faire là mais c'est
compliqué parce que vous avez des
militants qui viennent de différents
courants qui peuvent participer au
mouvement mais c'est des mouvements qui
de plus en plus ne veulent pas alors
c'est papa de tête qui dépasse au sens
strict du terme mais qui ont une
certaine horizontalité
qui refuse toute forme de verticalité et
tous les porte parole au fur et à mesure
son
sont soit éliminé après il faut faire
attention pour affiner sur le gilet
jaune les trois premières semaines du
mouvement des gels et jaune vous aviez
quand même c'est un peu cette même
sociologie de petits patrons qui étaient
présents autour des ronds points après
le mouvement a changé avec les militants
les plus radicaux qui sent qu'ils ont
pris en plus ou moins sur le long terme
de contrôle d'ubs du du mouvement des
gilet jaune mais au départ vous aviez
une sociologie qui peut petit patron
petit retraité qui peut se retrouver
effectivement
le
des retraités qui prennent leur voiture
pendant quatre jours décide de ce que ça
peut être des opérations escargot c'est
pas forcément des blocages mais vous
pouvez faire des maxi opération escargot
tout autour de paris pendant une journée
vous bloquez parler de la même manière
sans être en infraction quelques avec la
loi à part que vous ne pouvez pas rouler
en dessous d'un certain vitesse sur un
certain nombre dax donc à ce moment là
la wii vous verbaliser mais justement ce
mouvement très hétérogène et horizontale
qu'on a si vraiment remarqué tous me
fait dire que ceux des corps
intermédiaires n'ont pas prise dessus
c'est pour ça que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec vous sur la façon dont
macron à une inflation maîtrisée les
corps intermédiaires mais dans ce type
de mouvement je sais pas très bien ce
que les corps intermédiaires peuvent
réussir à faire pour en tout cas dans ce
qui relève du syndicalisme peut-être
mieux pour des associations encore que
ce soit pas évident parce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va avec
l'individualisme de notre société là
dedans donc ans est renversée votre
raisonnement s'il y avait des corps
intermédiaires et s'il était entendu
soutenu et cetera ce type de mouvement
aurait peut-être moins d espace oui j'en
suis pas sûr sur la question du vaccin
parce que le vaccin c'est pas du tout
quelque chose qui relève véritablement
du combat classique qu'on va dire
sociale ou syndicales peut-être que vous
avez raison mais peut-être aussi que non
on était quand même avant macron déjà
dans une forme de très faible
syndicalisation
dans milieu privé et les seuls endroits
où c'est encore un peu syndiqués on sait
très bien edf la sncf les enseignants
pas dans ce qui relève plus du public
honnêtement et ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on est dans ce recul mais les
associations auraient peut-être pu jouer
un rôle
plus important pour calmer le jeu mais
quand même on est beaucoup depuis
quelques temps dans l'indignation
indignez vous souvenez le mot cannes de
stéphane hessel tout ça pour les tous
derniers mots mathieu je reste
interloqué par le mode opératoire choisi
fhd l'idée de des véhicules parce qu'on
est des hommes seulement sommeil à moins
de faire du covoiturage mais la
dimension de lieux de sociabilité ou des
espaces de sociabilité qui avait créé à
la fois sur les réseaux et en physique
on en parlait tout à l'heure les jets
les jours nous que procurer une
manifestation que peut procurer une
occupation d'une place la cij chacun
dans sa voiture en tant qu'actionnaire
c'est complètement autre chose bon on
suivra sa merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le le titre de volume michel wieviorka
métamorphose ou d'échéance où va la
france est aux éditions rue de seine et
sylvain boulouque eux le pen le peuple
aux éditions atlandes julien le pen
militants syndicalistes et libertaire
des années 30